I also want to make sure
that I talk about your new clothing line
because I'm really excited about this.
I can't think also of someone who,
which is not an easy feat,
became such a red carpet it girl,
and you just broke the rules.
So what are you doing with clothes?
Thank you for saying that 'cause I love getting dressed
even though I ended up on every worst-dressed list
in America in my twenties, you couldn't stop me.
My mother cut them all out, she's so proud.
She was like, "It's so much chicer
"to be on the worst dressed list, this is fabulous."
She could not have been prouder.
So I was raised by a mom
who loves a good worst dressed list,
so I'm lucky in that regard.
But you know, it's been really interesting
just because, talking about self-love, I've been,
one of the things that was also interesting
about the commentary on the red carpet is I have been,
because a lot, because my body fluctuated
because of being sick,
also my body just fluctuated because you age,
I also went through menopause at 32.
I've been a size six on the red carpet.
I've been a size 16 on the red carpet.
The reactions that you get to your body are fascinating
and unbelievably different,
and dressing your body's a really different experience.
I've been able to walk into a store and put on anything
and I've been able to walk into the store and find nothing.
And I, now dressing my plus size body,
I found this amazing collaboration with 11 Honore
which is this amazing company
my friend Patrick Herning started
where he is taking companies
that have typically stocked clothing
in straight sizes, zero through 12,
and getting them to expand their sizing
so that women who, like me, are plus size
can access the clothing that they want
and see in magazines, and wouldn't typically have access to.
And I just, I love 11 Honore.
I love what they're doing.
And I just wanted to create a collection.
It's a capsule collection of five pieces
that I loved so much that just express the way
that I love to dress, which is in a way
that makes me feel powerful and professional,
but also still has like play and fun
and creative-
Yes!
And just like, I'm just feeling very sassy
in my blazer right now and my yellow shirt
and just feel in my body.
I'll just show you, I'm gonna stand up on Zoom
just to show you that I have some sassy scalloping
on my mini skirt.
I don't wanna be too daring right now.
Ooh, I see it, I see it!
(audience softly hooting)
Is that too much of a show and tell
for the American audience?
Nope, oh, I love it!
(audience loudly applauding)
I love those details.
(audience loudly cheering)
Thank you, and-
I can't tell you the amount of times I have walked
in my closet and felt not great 'cause I've,
I'm up, down, I'm here, there, but I love style.
And that is so personal which is-
So personal.
The way clothes should fit.
And one of the big revelations that I had as my body,
after my hysterectomy when I realized
I'm never going to be, I mean,
something that's amazing is when I first went on Girls,
the amount of criticism I received for my body,
people talked about me in ways
that I would never say on television
because they don't deserve human airtime.
But at that point I was like 50
to 60 pounds lighter than I am now.
And I look at that little girl who received
that feedback about her body,
like, the beauty that comes to me in work, in love, in sex,
like, I've never been denied anything
in this life by having like a big, beautiful, curvy body.
Because when I embrace it, I fill myself with love
and then that love comes out of me
and then that love comes back to me.
And so as sort of cheesy as it sounds,
like I just wanted that to be in these clothes
and like wrap up other women because that's been one
of the biggest lessons of my early thirties.
I'm really excited
that you are also working on something that you wrote was
possibly one of your most ambitious projects.
And when I hear Lena Dunham say she's working
on one of her most ambitious projects, I'm like, what is it?
It's so excited that you're excited.
Well, I'm in England right now 'cause I'm about
to start shooting a film that I've been trying to make
for almost 10 years.
It's called Catherine, Called Birdy
and it's a medieval coming of age comedy,
which I have to tell you
has some Ever After inspiration happening in it.
So it's kind of kismet that I'm getting to look
at your face right now
because I've been looking at your face
on some vision boards for my medieval coming of age comedy.
Danielle!
(Lena loudly laughing)
I can't believe what you just gave me,
the gift that you just gave me of yelling, "Danielle!"
Muah!
Good luck in London, go crush it.
I would love to see you when you're done.
I can't wait, I'm gonna give you a real hug.
Lena Dunham, 11 Honore,
(audience loudly applauding)
the Lena Dunham collection is out now.
This is the kind of conversations
I dreamt of signing up to this job.
Thank you for making my dreams
once again come true, Lena.
(bright music)